le comédien francis huster est aussi un
auteur son dernier ouvrage vient de
paraître albert camus est un combat pour
la gloire un testament imaginaire dans
lequel camus se raconte à travers
francis huster l'auteur qui sera présent
à montigny le bretonneux à la librairie
le pavé du canal le 20 avril de 15h à
17h pour une série de dédicaces sur son
dernier run dernier ouvrage il sera
aussi quelques heures plus tard à 20h30
à bois d'arcy à la grange de la
tramblais pour une représentation de son
spectacle bronx où il campe 18
personnages une plongée dans ce quartier
mythique de new york dans les années 60
alors que règne la loi de la mafia pour
patienter d'ici le 20 avril voici
quelques extraits de bronx justement il
est 3 heures du matin à new york dans le
bronx son temps des milliers de voix
dans ma tête
et il voit en particulier on l'appelait
sami
c'était le caïd du quartier bon avec à
sa gauche avec à sa droite c'était ses
gardes du corps
ils ressemblent à des frigos avec des
tati j'avais été témoin d'un meurtre
merci merci pour votre pardon mon père
c'était bien d'être catholique on aller
se confesser chaque semaine on était
tout neuf
allez vas-y pour le jo oui je vais faire
ce qu'il fallait faire
car il a fait alors est par exemple
j'adore ce monde et j'ai vu la rage dans
les jeux de mon père mais se sait que ça
ça quoi pas ça comme ça l'argent c'est
l'argent que j'ai économisé pas à
économiser 12 100 dollars qui domineront
chien revient dans la nuit jusqu'à
proche de mon fils
par contre il est clair pour commencer
tu me parle plus jamais comme ça j'ai
jamais dis à ton fils de faire quoi que
ce soit de mal
son propos c'est parce que tu dis c'est
ce qu'ils voient les voitures l'argent
les costumes les femmes enfin bonduelle
chéri j'ai proposé à mon fils d'aller
voir un match de baseball la semaine
dernière il a refusé
ben parce que mickey mantle par rapport
à mon loyer d'allissa j'y crois pas bien
bon on savait que francis huster ce sera
à la grange de la tramblais le 20 avril
à bois d'arcy